My Hope Is that as we all see as Joe
Biden is exposed as nothing he's not a
man anymore he's just a shell of a human
that all the people who defend him who
are all in on it because they all know
something's not right that it'll take
them all down
um here's Kamala we showed you this one
last week I think it's worth looking at
again Kamal is saying uh that you know
she'll she'll support him there is
speculation among some Democrats and
some Republicans that President Biden
won't run for re-election in 2024 what's
your message to those who say that
listen to President Biden he intends to
run
and if he does I intend to run with him
so there he all right the cackle now
this time you remember the video that I
showed you last week where she was
saying he's going to run again and she's
going like this this time she's taking
notes so she's not a yes he's going to
run again she knows he's not going to
run again she knows she's not running
with him she may run again not against
him she may run in instead of him but
she she knows it's a lie and she knows
something is wrong with him they all
know it they all know it uh remember AOC
at least she's being somewhat honest
she's saying she's not sure what she's
gonna do oh I just want to ask about
President Biden he is saying he's going
to run again in 2024 will you support
him
you know if the president chooses to run
again in 2024 I mean first of all I'm
focused on winning this majority right
now and preserving a majority this year
in 2022 so we'll cross that bridge when
we get to it but um but I think if if
the president has a vision and that's
something certainly we're all willing to
entertain and examine when the time
comes
that's not a yes
yeah you know I think we should endorse
when we get to it but I I believe that
the president has been doing a very good
job so far and
um you know should he run again I think
that I you know I think it's it's
we'll take a look at it
I cannot believe it despite the fact I
find her to be the most vapid shell
inauthentic
unpleasant dishonest really vile human
being who is here to only destroy
America I will give AOC credit she's
saying something a little bit kinda
close to the truth she's basically
saying hey we used you you old bastard
and she's not fully saying we're not
going to support you because she knows
she has to play the game of politics but
the way she's laughing and we'll get to
the decision all that she knows she
doesn't want to buy it and she wants a
true radical Socialist Communist someone
probably even worse than her and we'll
get to who that person might be in a few
minutes
um but I'll give her credit for saying
something kind honest as opposed to
Kamala who's pretending that Joe Biden
is going to run again and speaking of
pretending that Joe Biden is going to
run again here's gay Pete do you expect
President Biden to run for re-election
in 24 and if not will you run
yes I do expect him to run I'll support
him and let me tell you why he's going
to have a lot to be proud of and I'm
going to choose my words carefully
because I'm appearing as an official and
this is not a campaign-related
appearance but but I'm proud to be part
of this Administration that has done
such work to bring America back from the
brink of a recession to create record
job growth to build achievements that
would not have been thought possible
just a couple of years ago like the
bipartisan infrastructure law that that
I have the honor of working on you know
people scoffed at the idea that you
could get anything done on a bipartisan
basis yeah Pete is just he's just such
an inauthentic nothing I always describe
him he's just a suit he's just a suit
that they put a generic guy in who would
say all the generic stuff and then you
know you're just going to be this like
little nothing footnote in history the
fact that the interviewer was saying
well you run it's like they probably
want Peter on because he stands for
nothing right so it's just like you can
manipulate him in any which way possible
but he knows Joe Biden is not running
it's so idiotic to say that all this
stuff about the job growth yes if you
crush millions and millions of jobs
eventually the jobs will come back when
you let people out of their houses again
it's all lies gay Pete has no knowledge
of Transportation he was the mayor of
South Bend Indiana they said oh we need
a transportation secretary let's look at
the oppression Olympics people can we
get a lesbian with a limp no we don't
have a good one okay can we get a gay
guy I got one okay and can we find a
trans Health secretary got one okay and
do we have a black lesbian to be the
press secretary got one and do we have a
furry to be in charge of nuclear waste
or he got one of those too